it does not lie within any of our ream
it's to be entirely sane there are so
many powerful reasons why we must lack
an entirely even keel we have complex
histories we are heading towards the
ultimate catastrophe we are vulnerable
to devastating losses love will never go
wholly well the gap between our hopes
and our realities will be cavernous in
the circumstances what we should aim for
is not sanity but a wise knowledgeable
and self-possessed relationship to our
manifold insanities or what we might
term sane insanity the same insane
differ from the simply insane by virtue
of the honest and accurate grasp they
have on what is not entirely right with
them they may not be wholly balanced but
they don't have the additional folly of
insisting on their normalcy they can
admit with good grace and no particular
loss of dignity that of course they are
rather peculiar at a myriad of points
they don't go out of their way to hide
from us what they get up to in the night
in their sad moments when anxiety
strikes or during attacks of envy they
can at their best be dryly funny about
the tragedy of being human they lay bare
the fears doubts longings desires and
habits that don't belong to the story we
like to tell ourselves about sanity
they don't make ready confessions to let
themselves off the hook or just to be
eccentric
they simply realize the unreasonableness
of expecting to be reasonable
all the time they warn others as far as
possible in advance of what being around
them might involve and apologize
promptly for their failings as soon as
they have manifested themselves they
offer their friends and companions
accurate maps to their craziness which
is just about the most generous thing
one can do to anyone who has to live
around us
the same insane among us are not a
special category of the mentally unwell
they represent the most evolved
possibility for a mature human being
thank you for watching we've designed a
tote bag to help us all acknowledge that
no one is normal please follow the link
on your screen now to find out more
you